hello and congratulations on your
exhibition
at the upcoming virtual event
on behalf of lab roots we are very
excited to be working with you and
putting together your virtual booth
for the upcoming virtual event at this
point
you should have received your booth
materials which contain the booth grid
that we will be covering
this video will take you through your
booth grid
the booth grid contains sections you
will fill out with your company's
information
and then send to us along with any
virtual booth assets
such as logos images pdf documents
videos and anything else we might need
to build out your virtual booth
not all fields or sections are mandatory
but all of it is recommended to make
your booth
look and feel more interactive let's get
started
the first page of the booth grid is a
general overview
there is a field here to enter your
booth's objectives to help us understand
what you want to achieve with your booth
in this virtual event and allow us to
make any recommendations that may be
helpful to you
in achieving your booth objectives and
goals
below the objectives field is a table of
contents for your reference
and below that is the hightail upload
link where you'll be able to upload your
booth grid once you have completed it
as well as any files we'll need for the
booth building process
pages 2 and 3 contain the virtual booth
reference overview of design elements
information and features please use this
as a reference guide to help you
identify the sections that you are
working on in the booth grid
the first section of the booth grid is
the company contact information
please keep in mind that this is the
information an attendee who visits your
booth will find
if they have any questions or inquiries
and not what the booth builder would use
to contact you
with any questions or concerns during
your booth building process
section 2 is the about us field where
you have up to 2 000 characters maximum
including spaces to describe your
company
we can also hyperlink urls to send
attendees out to an external site
where they can view more information
about your company section 3 is the
booth template and booth floor
you'll first need to take a look at the
booth template images to choose from
on pages 9-12 and floor options on page
14.
once you've selected your booth and
floor you can fill in the booth template
number and floor number
so your booth production builder knows
which templates to use to build out your
booth
section 4 is the booth background in
windows you'll find the background
options on page 15
and window options on page 14. please
fill in your selections in section 4.
section 5 is the booth chat features you
can select one or all of these
booth chat features depending on what
you are looking for the choices are
public chat
one-to-one chat private chat video chat
virtual badge chat queue and info card
the public chat is something we do
standardly across the board
for all booths but this is still an
option whether you want to include it or
not
public chat is where all attendees and
all booth reps can chat in one area
and will be seen by anyone and everyone
who visits your booth
this is a great way to start up
conversations and from here take an
attendee
into a private chat depending on what
they are looking for and questions they
may have
one-on-one chat and private chat
features allow
attendees and a live booth
representative to connect directly
but the private chat will not save any
transcripts
we now offer a video chat option for a
more personal conversation
a virtual badge is a great option if you
decide not to include any live virtual
booth representative
on the live event date when attendee
clicks on the virtual badge a
notification will be sent to an email of
your choice
where you will then be able to follow up
via email with an attendee
a chat queue is helpful if you do have a
live virtual booth representative on the
live event date
when the attendee clicks on the chat
queue they will be added to the queue of
waiting attendees in the virtual booth
representative dashboard
where a representative will be able to
see who is waiting to chat and from
there engage in a chat with an attendee
and lastly is the info card this is a
cool feature which allows attendees to
see more information
on the representative who they might be
chatting with this information can be
helpful to an attendee
if they have a specific question or
inquiry and can contact that
representative directly
on page five step six is social media
you can choose up to five social media
sites that your company might be signed
up on
to provide within your booth for
attendees to click on
this will take an attendee to an
external window outside of the event so
please keep that in mind
you can choose from facebook twitter
linkedin
instagram pinterest youtube or
enter any social media site not listed
here
section 7 is the booth representative
sign up
we will need the first and last name of
your booth representatives
as well as their email addresses to get
them set up on the backend
and give them access prior to the
virtual event date so that they can get
familiar with the booth representative
dashboard
section 8 is a booth representative
image you find all the reference booth
rep image options on page 16.
fill in the rep number you selected or
you can use
a custom rep image specifications are
listed if you would like to use an image
that is not provided in the booth grid
or would like to personalize it and
provide an image of a person who works
at your company
sections 9 10 11 are the small screen
and large screen options
you'll see that located within each
booth template are two small screens and
one large screen
you can place a static image within each
screen which can be clickable to a click
action
a content screen a rotating banner or a
doorway link
a click action allows a screen to be
clickable to an external url
or a single piece of content keep in
mind that
external urls can be opened up in an
iframe
or can send an attendee out to a new
window
a content screen would open a content
window
where attendees can view multiple pieces
of content
such as web links pdf documents videos
and webinars that can be listed
the rotating banner consists of multiple
images
that can also be clickable only to an
external url
but cannot link content lastly
is the doorway link a doorway link will
send attendees to a separate area in the
virtual environment
for any questions on click action
customizations
please inquire with your sales
representative
section 13 is the booth greeting this
option is a great way to greet attendees
which is
automatically shown to visitors who
enter your booth the first time
if they were to leave and come back
another time they would need to click on
the booth grading to view it again
the greeting can include an image or
logo and audio
or a welcome video the specifications
are listed below
each option section 14 is logos and
custom colors
we'll need your website logo and booth
logo the booth logo is the most
important
and the specs for each are listed you
can also choose the primary and
secondary colors that we can inject
within your booth
we'll just need the hex or rgb code for
your primary and secondary colors
to adjust within the booth template that
you chose
section 15 is the broadcast messages
this option lets you schedule one
announcement event wide
per day and can be linked to your booth
please contact your sales representative
if you want to schedule more pages 7 and
8 are your booth assets
section 16 are the web links to any
external or company urls
that you would like to provide in your
booth for attendees to visit
we'll just need the web link title a
description and url
if you have more urls that can be listed
in the booth grid
you can create a separate file such as a
word document or an excel spreadsheet of
the additional
web links for your booth section 17 is
literature all pdf documents are listed
here with the category
the title description and file name to
match it with the appropriate literature
title
section 18 is the presentation or
webinars
this is the area where you can provide a
link to your presentations or webinars
or your video files we'll just need your
presentation title
description and either url to webcast
such as
youtube or vimeo or the actual file name
for your.mov.mp4.mpegor.wmv files
this last section is a survey that your
attendees can take within your booth
option 1 allows you to provide the url
to an existing survey
you have already built option 2 allows
us to build a survey for
you through surveymonkey with the survey
title questions and
answers you provide
on behalf of lab roots we are excited to
be working with you in putting together
your company's
virtual booth for the upcoming virtual
event
thank you